Major breaking news. A unanimous Supreme
Court decision was just released that is
going to be hugely beneficial to the
Second Amendment and to the gun industry
specifically. That's right. The Supreme
Court just decided Cox Communications
versus Sony. This is a big deal, folks,
because it talks about if you have a
lawful product in America, the mere fact
that someone can misuse it does not make
you liable for that misuse. This is a
big deal, folks, because if you cannot
buy guns, if you cannot make guns and
you cannot get guns, we don't have guns.
And if we don't have guns, we don't have
a second amendment right to keep and
bear arms. Even if it's in writing in
the Bill of Rights, it will be a
parchment tiger. Not effective at all.
But this Supreme Court decision today 90
in the ruling makes it clear that we're
going to be okay moving forward. But
let's break it all down when we come
right back.
Hey folks, I'm Mark Smith, host of the
four box of Don, proud American gun
owner, constitutional attorney, member
of the United States Supreme Court Bar,
and I'm proud to say the top voice of
the Second Amendment in America. Thank
you. 2025 and 2026 Gundy's awards. And
as a reminder, on Friday night, I'll be
the keynote speaker at the annual Gun
Owners of America activist dinner. So,
if you're going to be out there in
Arizona on Friday and Saturday, uh head
on over to the Gun Owners of America
event and check it out. And uh if you
come on over then say hello to me
because I will be there giving the big
speech on Friday night and looking
forward to it in Arizona in just a
couple days. All right folks. So this is
a huge deal. This is actually something
believe it or not I wrote about in 2020.
the importance of a Supreme Court
decision from many years ago written by
anti-gun Justice Justice John Paul
Stevens who specifically in that case
talked about how you cannot ban products
that are lawful in America that have
lawful good uses just because some
miscreant can take that product and
misuse it. That was the case involving
Sony and Betamax. We'll get to that one
second. And I wrote about that in a
major law reviewview article explaining
how that precedent can give rise to
helping to protect America's gun
industry and gun owners and the like
from insane lawsuits and lawfare brought
by people that want to destroy guns in
the Second Amendment in America. So
today we have a vindication of my theory
because the US Supreme Court literally
just a couple hours ago in the decision
of Cox Communications versus Sony just
reaffirmed that Betamax decision and
Justice Stevens views in that Betamax
and Sony decision which we'll get to in
one second and said again in a 9 to0
unanimous decision written by none other
than Justice Clarence Thomas that the
mere fact that Someone could misuse a
lawful product does not make the creator
or provider of that lawful product
liable for the damages that the person
suffers. And that the right answer is
that you should go after the bad actor,
the copyright infringer, the criminal,
the murderer, the rapist, the thug.
You don't go after the people that
provided the means by which they went
out and committed the crime, i.e. the
baseball bat to hit someone over the
head, the gun to shoot someone with, or
in this case, the internet service
provider provider services, the internet
services provided by the ISP that
allowed people according to Sony to take
their copyrighted material and steal it
from Sony because the internet service
provider of Cox Communications allowed
that to occur. And the Supreme Court 9
to0 just says no can do. That is not how
American law works. And obviously, you
can see the analogy here, which is what
the anti-gunners try to do. They want to
hold gun owners and they want to hold
the gun industry and gun makers liable
for the acts of people that misuse
firearms to commit crime. people over
whom none of us have any sway, none of
us even know their names, and they go
out and do crazy stuff with guns or
whatever, and next thing you know, the
anti-gun movement is trying to use
lawfare to destroy the gun industry, to
destroy gun owners and anyone associated
with the gun space. So, with that said,
let's turn specifically to this case,
and then we'll tie it in to what I wrote
and how this is great for the Second
Amendment movement moving forward. And
that's this. In this particular case,
there was the Sony music entertainment
has all this content. They have music,
they have videos and all this stuff,
right? You have Cox Communications that
provides internet service, meaning
access to the internet. So, what
happened was there were users of the of
the Cox Communications internet service
provider, right? The Cox Communications
would provide this internet service,
internet access to these people. And
some of these people would take products
and videos and or music from Sony and
they would illegally download it in
violation of Sony's copyrights on the
music or the videos or whatever it was.
So what Sony did is they sued Cox
Communications and this sounds very
familiar to you in the Second Amendment
space. And they sued Cox Communications
and they said, "Hey, Cox Communications
has been providing internet service,
internet access to all these people. We
at Sony have identified these particular
people as the infringers that have taken
Sony material, Sony music, Sony videos,
and they have used the cop's pipeline of
data, if you will, to download all this
copyrighted material. So the infringers,
i.e., you know, Bob at the coffee shop
or Joe at Starbucks or someone else at
the internet cafe or someone in their
home, whatever it was, some random dude
would use the internet service provided
by Cox to download the copyrighted
material in violation of Sony's
copyright, which is not just a civil
problem, it can also be a criminal
problem. So Sony sued Cox Communications
that says you provided the internet
service that these people in turn use to
illegally download our meaning Sony's
copyrighted material and we're going to
hold you Cox Communications liable for
helping these people commit these
crimes. And Cox basically says like the
gun industry would say or like we would
say in the Second Amendment community go
after the criminal. Don't go after the
maker of the gun or the maker of the
baseball bat or the maker of the rope or
the maker of the steak knife. Go after
the person that misused the product. And
that is exactly what the Supreme Court 9
to0 basically said today. They said,
"Look, Sony, if someone in illegal
illegally infringed on your copyright,
go sue them. Go get them. Don't try to
do an end run to go after Cox
Communications simply because presumably
they've got the money and maybe the
infringers don't have the money to pay
the bill. So here is what Justice Thomas
had to say and say no can do because
there's lawful uses of this internet
service by Cox Communications. It's not
appropriate for Sony to be able to sue
them and make any money. And by the way,
as you listen to this, it's exactly
analogous to the gun situation where
they're trying to hold gun makers and
gun owners liable for the misbehavior of
the miscreants who go out and misuse
guns to commit crimes. Here's what
Justice Thomas said h said today on
behalf of the United States Supreme
Court. Countless people use the internet
for legal activities, but some use it to
illegally share copyrighted work such as
songs and movies. The Copyright Act
authorizes copyright owners to sue these
copyright infringers. In this case,
however, instead of suing those
infringers, the copyright owner sued
petitioners Cox Communications and its
subsidiary who provided who provided the
internet connections that the infringers
used. They contended that Cox was itself
liable for copyright infringement
because it continued to provide known
infringes with internet access. Based on
this theory of infringement, the
respondents, that would be Sony Music
Entertainment and other major copyright
owners secured a $1 billion or billion
dollar verdict against Cox. The US Court
of Appeals for the Fourth Circuit agreed
that Cox provided internet service to
known infringers, it was a willful
infringer itself. That's right. Under
our Now, when the Supreme Court says,
"But under our precedence, a company is
not liable as a copyright infringer for
merely providing a service." Sound
familiar? For merely providing a service
to the general public with knowledge
that it will be used by some to infringe
copyrights accordingly. Reverse.
We reverse. That's fantastic news. And
again, the reason why you tune into the
four boxes diner is to make these
connections. They will not otherwise get
connected. Right? As you can see by
analogy, the Supreme Court is saying
that legally you cannot hold liable the
provider of a service or a product just
because they know that some narr
somewhere out there is going to misuse
the service or the product in some
illegal way. That is not enough to
create liability on the person that
provides the service. Which is again, if
you had it any other way, there would be
no baseball bat companies, no knife
companies, no rope companies, no car
companies. People drive drunk, right?
There'd be no, you know, home recording
devices. People can illegally download
videos with them or do other bad stuff
with that, right? Never ever ends. It
goes on and on and on. In fact, for that
matter, you could get rid of computers
because people use computers to commit
crimes. They use telephones to commit
crimes. They commit fraud on the phone.
And it would be absurd to think you
could sue a telephone provider because,
you know, cartel members use the phone
and texting service to, you know,
perpetrate some terrible crime in Mexico
or whatever, right? It's absurd. That is
exactly what the Supreme Court had to
say. Now, the reason why this all gets
connected up and why it's great uh to
see sort of my views have some
vindication here is that the basis for
this entire decision of saying that you
cannot hold Cox Communications liable is
Justice John Paul Stevens decision in
Betamax. And it was in that decision
that I talked all about in 2020 as the
basis for protecting the Second
Amendment movement and the gun industry
from lawfare. So, here's what the
Supreme Court in this Cox communications
decision had to say about Justice John
Paul Stevens, who isn't really an
anti-gunner in all respects. In fact, it
was Justice John Paul Stevens that put
that ridiculous, terrible language in
part three of Heler that Justice Scalia
was not going to insert, but it was
Justice John Paul Stevens who urged
Justice Kennedy to put that language in
part three and Heler in. And that's all
the language about sensitive places. And
you know, this is not to say that all
these other gun laws are a problem or
all that stuff. That all comes because
of Justice John Paul Stevens. And
Justice John Paul Stevens, it wrote just
the following, which is actually very
good for us. Although maybe he did not
see down the chessboard enough. But
let's turn to what he said um and how
the US Supreme Court refers to Justice
John Paul Stevens in this Cox
Communications. So, here is Justice
Thomas relying upon the anti-gunner,
Justice John Paul Stevens in ruling for
Cox Communications, which is essentially
a standin for the American gun industry
and the American gun space. Check it
out. Justice Thomas writes, quote, "A
service is tailored to infringement if
it is not capable of substantial or
commercially significant non-infringing
uses." In Sony, which is the Justice
John Paul Stevens case, in Sony,
copyright owners sued the maker and the
retailers of the Betamax video tape
recorder. The tape recorder could be
used to record copyrighted television
programs for later personal viewing,
which would not constitute infringement.
On the other hand, it could also be used
to reproduce and sell copyrighted
television programming, which would
constitute infringement. The lower court
found that the Betamax maker liable
because the tape recorder was not
suitable for any substantial
non-infringing use and infringement was
either the most conspicuous use or the
major or the major use of the Metamax
product. This Supreme Court reversed
however concluding that the Betamax is
capable of substantial non-infringing
uses like personal use. So sale of such
equipment to the general public does not
constitute contributo negligence. That's
great stuff. Again, take out the word
Cox Communications. Insert the word of
anyone in the gun space, any gun
company, any gun retailer, any gun
seller, any gun maker, it doesn't
matter. Stick it in there. And if
they're if some anti-gun group or
anti-guners try to use the theory of
going after the gun industry on the
grounds that they provided the service
or the product that some criminal
miscreant, misused. Well, this is going
to be very favorable Preston for them to
use moving forward. And by the way, I
made this exact point discussing that
Betamax case, the Sony case, which the
Supreme Court literally just relied upon
today. I discussed this several years
ago in a major law review article. And
the title of the article was a judicial
teaching point, the lesson of the late
Justice John Paul Stevens in Sony versus
Universal City Studios as a response to
civil lawfare. And when I wrote that
article, no one else had connected the
dots about the very important uh
decision by Justice John Paul Stevens.
Again, no friend to guns, no friend to
freedom, no friend to the Second
Amendment, but his opinion serves as a
brick, as I see it, as a precedent in
our favor. And now in addition to citing
to the Sony Betamax case from Justice
John Paul Stevens a couple decades ago,
we can now also cite in favor of the
Second Amendment to this Cox
Communications decision just today from
the Supreme Court. And just to let you
know uh what I had to say about it in my
law review article, here's how I
connected all the dots up back then.
Check it out. My conclusion is Justice
John Paul Stevens is a true friend of
economic liberty when presiding over
politically motivated lawsuits against
product manufacturers. It is ironic, but
despite his decision in Sony versus
Universal City Studios, Justice John
Paul Stevens later showed himself to be
no friend of the right to keep and bear
arms. After his retirement, Justice
Stevens called for the repeal of the
Second Amendment. This occurred after
his descent in the Supreme Court's
District of Columbia versus Heler
decision, which in a quintessentially
originalist ruling upheld the individual
right of law-abiding citizens to possess
firearms. But judges can articulate
legal principles that are truer than
they know. and whether he would have
recognized the implications. The sound
logic of Justice Stevens decision in the
Betamax case that lawful industries are
not to blame for the third party misuse
of their products should vindicate
should vindicate gun makers and gun
sellers today. In the Betamax case,
Justice Stevens proved a true friend of
liberty. His reasoning should serve as a
judicial teaching point for judges today
when asked to whom the gun industry or
any industry for that matter is
responsible for harms caused by third
parties over whom they have no control.
Congress embraced Justice Stevens logic
in enacting PLA to stem the use of
lawfare against respected and
law-abiding American businesses. Courts
today must honor Congress's choice, not
ignore it. And as for those jurists
presiding over cases involving the
application of the placa law, they would
do well to heed the learned reasoning of
Justice Stevens in Betamax. And for
those of you who don't remember, PLA is
just the federal law that preempts state
laws that prevent um gun companies from
being sued over the misbehavior of third
parties uh third party criminals over
whom the gun companies for example have
no control. PLA stands for the
protection, lawful commerce and arms
act. by the way, enacted after 9/11 with
the support of the Pentagon and police,
by the way. All right, folks. There you
have it. Big win for the Second
Amendment, although it may not be
obvious today. Big win for the American
gun industry, although again, it may not
be obvious, but that's why you have the
four box of Diner to make things that
are not obvious obvious to America,
which is what I hopefully have just done
with this video. So, with that said, if
you're going to be out in Arizona, make
sure you check out my keynote speech on
Friday night if you're going to be at
the dinner. Uh, and otherwise, I
hopefully see you on Saturday at the
event. Uh, Gun Owners of America again
in Arizona. Then again, thank you for
tuning in and don't forget to check me
out on xfbox dinner and subscribe both
to YouTube and to Rumble and I'll talk
to you again real soon here at the four
boxes.
Orders up table 2 A.